absteigen
ich meine wie lange hält die phalanx der
parteien das ist in wahrheit meint ist
doch ihren jubeltag in görlitz hinten
links monz kommst du lernst görlitz
freut sich jetzt über gärten ist richtig
machen das können sie mal ich war mal in
görlitz auch nicht vorgehalten zu sagen
im wunderschönen monat mai sondern auch
rentner das ja auch egal denn er ist
deutscher rentner aber verhindern was
und da war jetzt oberbürgermeister war
und am ende damit in der stichwahl der
kandidat der cdu beziehungsweise der
technokrat gewinnt gegen den garstigen
afd kandidaten machen sich dann sich
lustig moment ich mache mich befolgen
ist lustig ich mache mich darüber dass
ich statt das im zweiten wahlgang alle
parteien ausser der verlief also alle
geben sich hinter diesen mangel total
ehrbaren mann gestellt haben sind
sozusagen ich mehr angetreten die grüne
und die linke ist die sind nicht mehr
angetreten damit der andere quasi alle
stellen auf denen diese ja ja und jetzt
feiern alle parteien sich ab das ist der
afg mal so richtig gegeben haben dass
das bollwerk der damm der demokraten
könnte noch überall lagen erhält ja dann
die demokraten das hier richtig gut aus
aber so lange hält ja und das suggeriert
natürlich die ard ist keine
demokratische partei das ist natürlich
quatsch sie stellt sich zur wahl sich
wird gewählt sie kriegt ergebnisse sie
hat meinetwegen und demokraten in ihren
reihen aber als partei ist natürlich
eine demokratische partei als die haare
mit verkaufsfläche entschuldigung nach
den satz noch in das system in
anführungsstrichen von dem die ard ja
immer so die firma tore spricht dieses
system sieht sich zu tode
noch zwei solcher see gewesen görlitz
und dann machen wir einfach 50 passiert
etwas was sie schon mitbekommen haben
ist dass die demokratie und da hört der
spaß jetzt ganz kurz mal auf die
demokratie schafft sich aber kann sich
abschalten mit demokratischen mitteln
das haben wir in osteuropa gesehen in
polen in ungarn wo das was wir liberale
demokratien dort in wahrheit so gar
nicht mehr existiert unabhängige justiz
freie presse funktionierende
zivilgesellschaft die nicht von
staatlichen stellen unter druck gesetzt
wird und so weiter das heißt und das ist
alles
ganz demokratischen mitteln gelaufen
herr orban ist kein demokrat jedenfalls
nicht in dem sinne wie wir das irgendwie
gehört nicht dass unsere leute so alles
gar nicht mehr in die eu aufgenommen
werden das heißt die demokratie kann
sich mit demokratischen mitteln
abschaffen einer partei kann ja in einem
demokratischen system ist sie haben
minutenlang sekunden lang geredet das
darf ich jetzt auch eine partei kann in
einem demokratischen system einen platz
haben und demokratisch gewählt sein
und trotzdem kann ich demokratische
partei sein und für die fdp gilt das
meiner meinung nach denn ist eine
antiliberale partei die im fundamental
gegen unser system ist aber aber die
grünen sind auch eine antiliberale
partei sogar ist die spd eine
antiliberale partei weil die fdp eine
liberale partei sind die spender in
deutschland
ich finde sie machen sich sie machen es
sich viel zu einfach sie machen ist sich
sie schlagen diese partei die ich
wirklich nicht verteidige die ich
wirklich mindestens in großen teilen für
abscheulich und nicht wählbar halte sie
machen es sich zu einfach wenn sie sagen
die gehirns demokratische spektrum und
die können wir da einfach aus ganzen
irgendwann grenzen sie in görlitz hat er
am ende 44 prozent bekommen wollen sie
sagen das waren 44 prozent
undemokratische stimmen er machte sie
sich zu einfach wenn sie das als spiel
aufstellung für die auseinandersetzung
mit der dogan wird auch gewählt in der
türkei man dass das ist doch an ein
paradox unserer unseres unseres systems
die müssen sie sich auch mal stellen die
zahl der stimmen für eine partei
bedeutet nicht dass diese partei deshalb
eine höhere demokratische legitimation
ein ganz gefährlicher sagt habe ich
übrigen habe ich hier bin ist oder herr
erdogan ich meine ist seit ich hatte den
rat ist politiker war die mehrheit
bekommt nein na ja also das habe ich
nicht gesagt
da funktionieren nicht mehr richtig ganz
kurzarbeit das noch wenn sie müssen was
gegen tun nicht fern zu bleiben
doch wir bleiben doch stehen auf den
kern zurückkam den sie haben doch recht
sie haben das dass das schrecklicher
dieser mit dem ja eben sehen dass das
problem ist natürlich dass sie recht
haben es ist natürlich nicht gut wenn
ein mitglied des landtags von der
linkspartei
nach dieser wahl twittert heute zum
ersten mal cdu gewählt fühlt sich
komisch an musste aber sein
das ist natürlich in der tat da hat er
recht das ist nur ein prima alarmismus
finde ich der der dem system noch einmal
in anführungsstrichen
nicht gut und dann wenn man die wahl hat
zwischen faschisten auf der einen seite
und allen anderen demokraten nach der
anderen
dann muss man es halt so machen ja wenn
ich die wahl hätte zwischen faschisten
und dem tod oder ich weiß nicht was das
darin liegt das problem dass in
frankreich moment moment darin liegt
auch das problem das ich so sehr
alarmistisch wie ich finde aufpumpen
ja das dann natürlich keine alternative
bleibt außer linkspartei cdu fdp und
grüne und ich weiß wie und sp lebens
wieder nachgibt gehen zusammen
verwischen ihre unterschiede stellen sie
hinter diesen einmal wir wollen dir also
welche politik soll jetzt der arme
kollege machern der gewählt worden ist
jaja octavian ursu hast ja mal mit
rumänischen firma toll und der eu
politikern ganzjähriger vernünftiger
mann ich glaube das plakat am ende jedes
vernunft wählen und genauso war es aber
vernunft oder sie sofort das ist ja
jetzt kein politisches programm mehr
dass ich nach parteifarben organisieren
lässt ja und wenn die komplett
verwischen zahlen sie ein auf die
diffamierung des systems durch die afg
das heißt alle gleich unterscheidet euch
an ist auch nicht gut man als als in wir
wollen jetzt nicht das kleine görlitz so
schön es ist mit dem großen in der tat
noch ein bisschen schülerin frankreich
vergleichen aber ich tue es jetzt mal
trotzdem mal als analyst die stichwahl
war zwischen makro und und le pen und
europas oder linker war deshalb
aufgerufen zur wahl von makro das heißt
ein linker ein sozialist ruft auf einen
neoliberalen zu wählen denn das ist
marco krasser knallharter neoliberaler
weil er sagt wenn ich die wahl zwischen
neoliberaler faschisten sowie le pen
weiß ich ich muss mal conwert das hat
was gesagt das war für mich einer der
wichtigsten politischen momente der
letzten zehn jahre ehrlich gesagt und
eine kapitulation unseres gesamten
demokratischen system und sie haben
jetzt im kleinen görlitz nochmal aber
meine frage was ist denn wenn wir diese
beschissene alternative dazu
die alternative dazu ist ich glaube
adressiert sich der wunsch nach einer
alternative vornehmlich an die cdu/csu
also in görlitz an die cdu in ganz
ostdeutschland sie müssen etwas tun um
diese partei zum beispiel zu spalten
denn die ard jetzt seien sie so viele
einmal dass nicht alles faschisten uns
nicht
des neonazis im gegenteil das sind ganz
normale leute dabei die der cdu der spd
der fdp den rücken gekehrt haben
der kollege der in görlitz angetreten
das sind fast gewonnen hätte kommt aus
der fdp
die sind jetzt irgendwie nicht mit der
glatze und braun lackiert geboren worden
wirklich nicht und die gibt es da drin
ist gibt einen flügel der ist absolut
indiskutabel und undemokratisch jetzt
könnte man ja versuchen diesen flügel
abzuspalten beziehungsweise jene leute
aus der partei zurück zu holen die ja
auch im bundestag sitzen und setzt es
auch ganz normale leute von der afg ja
das wäre die aufgabe der cdu
diese partei zu spalten oder sie aber in
eine häutung zu zwingen und was um am
ende standen am ende und ich sag's euch
dazu um am ende mit denen zu koalieren
ist doch klar
genauso wie herr maß angesagt hat ein
sehr erfolgreicher höchst prominenter
politischer beamter unseres landes herr
maßen der einen maßlosen unsinn geredet
hat als er jetzt gesagt hat natürlich
wird man wahrscheinlich irgendwann mit
der afg auch koalieren müssen oder wie
der frühere bundesbank der je älter er
wird desto klaren sicher und
konservativer wird der gesagt es gibt
jetzt viele rechte im land und dann muss
man irgendwie auch anders mal mit dem
umgehen weil das ist jetzt hat sony
müssen wir eben auch auf die irgendwie
so zu gehen und so kann man auf mich
weil sie nicht müssen wir nicht naja wie
viel wollen sie international oder
fangen sie an aufzuwachen wenn sie 50
prozent dann wollen sie dann also ich
verstehe sich jetzt nicht meine ich
dachte wir haben hier so quasi so
liberale errungenschaften wie
pressefreiheit unabhängigkeit der justiz
und so weiter 90 die alle irgendwie
haben das schon mitbekommen was in
sachsen teilweise in der justiz los ist
die staatsanwälte wie die da sozusagen
die rechten kameraden laufen lassen und
den linken praktisch irgendwie bei jedem
parkticket irgendwie so einbuchten
wollen und so herzlichen glückwunsch
wollen sie dass die ticken so diesen wir
wollen den staat übernehmen
da muss ich eher sagen kein fußbreit den
faschisten entschuldigung auch wenn das
für sie wie eine floskel ist kein
fußball den faschisten ist also auch
nicht er war und glaube ich hatte auch
eine historische anleihen aus ganz ganz
schlimme momente geschenkt damit lösen
sie das problem nicht
wenn sie das so raus definieren dann
werden sie das problem nicht lösen das
problem jahre schreibt verstehen sie ich
vergesse genau alles faschisten und man
müsste doch versuchen auch die cdu über
meinetwegen ein koalitionskrach dass man
sagen stolperte bei ihren namen sondern
über ihre beiden beinen
die kann ja nicht einmal zwingend
absetzen ohne nachher dann wieder
zurückrudern zu müssen jetzt in görlitz
genau hat sie gesagt
herzlichen glückwunsch unser
bürgermeister haben wir toll gemacht
dann kommen ja ich gesagt habe jetzt gar
nicht mehr sagt zwar die linke und die
grünen alle zusammen sorry und dann sie
so ja noch mal stimmt also das haben
auch andere mal heimlich ins was sie
damals kam er seit er weiß ich nicht ob
dieses kann so geschickt jetzt müssen
sie erstmal versuchen dass die cdu habe
den ehrgeiz entwickelt den die spd
übrigens längst aufgegeben hat und die
npd ich bin nämlich wir nun nicht zur
kenntnis dass die arbeit dass die
arbeiter und angestellten inzwischen zu
afd gelaufen die eu arbeite und
glaubwürdig sie soll das bloß noch nicht
die spd ist bereits gestorben sie hat
das bloß noch nicht mitbekommen
es gibt sie einen film mit bruce willis
wo er tot ist und es nicht weiß und ganz
am ende des films guckt an sich runter
und sieht er hat so riesige löcher im
bauch und er ist längst gestorben war
die ganze hatten gespenst ja das ist die
spd aber sieht minister als ich runter
kommt marco verdammt das war sigmar
gabriel kommt dann sagen sie ja das
kenne ich kenne das ja wo er dann können
wir mal zum ernst lager zurückkehren ist
ja nun wirklich ein bisschen ernst wie
lange wollen sie noch zuschauen
die insbesondere im osten sich zur
echten mehrheitsfähigen partei
entwickelt ohne irgendwie strategischen
ankündigungen und ihre ganze antwort ist
damit sind faschisten ja toll dann muss
der arzt darüber mal verändern wenn im
moment im moment wird in deutschland
viel darüber diskutiert wo ist die
grenze zwischen in einem liberalen
system noch vorstellbaren konservatismus
und dem was wir eigentlich in einem die
bahn system nicht mehr akzeptieren
wollen rechts reaktionären oder
rechtsextremistischen denken wo ist die
grenze rüstigen alten baby aus ja und wo
ist dass die sieger aus dem jetzt der
mord entstanden ist offenkundig an dem
an dem wir an dem hessischen
kommunalpolitiker happy der offenkundig
aus diesem milieu heraus ermordet worden
ist und was immer die afg in dieses
milieu an antreten hat klar gehört
gekappt und möglicherweise muss man eben
diesen teil der partei rausschmeißen
ergeben sich auch nur geht darum dass
man überhaupt mal anfängt darüber
nachzudenken wie man strategisch auf die
auf die mehrheitsfähigkeit der aasee in
bestimmten regionen deutschlands
reagiert ohne sich total brown zu
besudeln sich gemein zu machen mit
diesem teil der partei um am ende den
größeren teil dieser partei hoffentlich
im spektrum im demokratischen spektrum
zu halten und über koalition so wie das
bei den grünen ja auch der fall war
wieder quasi zu zivilisieren das war
doch machte jetzt mit den grünen wolle
ich vergleiche die afg mit den grünen
die grünen haben begonnen und hatten
dabei die mine hallnor decoder ist war
die blöcke der der der cdu und grüne
also sind es genau was sie wollen weil
jetzt geleiten ihn jetzt alle maßstäbe
komplett nein das ist genau die art von
französischem geredet die wirklich also
da die grünen hatten in zur
gründungszeit und im wan ab in die
parlamente natürlich ein hardcore
kommunistischen flügel und den haben sie
irgendwann zivilisiert schrägstrich
abgespalten das war nötig um diese
partei quasi gängig zu machen in unserem
parteien system in unserem mehrheits
konsensual koalitions system natürlich
und das braucht die afg auf ihre art
genauso wie manch einen ganzen prozesse
deutlich schneller durch als die grünen
das heißt also bei rund 120 prozent bei
den grünen hat es um die 35 jahre
gedauert bis herr harbeck vielleicht
kanzlerkandidat werden kann sieht man
bei der ft geht das schneller
ich weiß noch nicht denn die cdu und
auch die spd ist und auf die arbeiter in
füssen spuckt weil sie ihr vieh
schmutzig sind weil sie ja bei der fdp
waren da müssen das ja alles arbeiter
faschisten sein so wie sie sagen würden
wenn das so anhält diese sprachlosigkeit
diese ideenlosigkeit im umgang ja dann
werden wir das deutlich schneller leben
meine liebe aufsteiger ich hoffe nicht
beibehalten
[Musik]